Good morning, John.
I very much enjoy making things.
And I think that most people enjoy making
things- making songs, making scarves, making
video blogs, making books, making it rain
like Roger...
People that like, take things that are inside
of their head and make them real in the real
world.
And this is hard, but I've been doing it for
a while now and I'm getting better at it.
I think that's because of a combination of
attitudes and resources that I now have.
And for other people who want to make things
and are maybe have a hard time doing it, I
wanted to share my process in the form of
a case study: readit1st.com, which I launched
last night.
I had the idea over a year ago, and the process
of having and idea is very "plllblkdsj."
That just has to happen.
I liked the idea though, because it had a
lot of the things that I need for good ideas.
One: It promotes something that I love: reading.
Two: Through advertising, it could potentially
actually employ a writer.
And I would love to be responsible for a writer
having a job.
Three: It seemed kind of Nerdfightastic.
It seemed kinda like something that Nerdfighters
would enjoy.
But first, before nerdfighteria, I had to
explain the idea to Katherine.
Katherine is my wife and she is also my number
one wall at which to throw ideas, and if they
stick to her, then this is a very good sign.
She's smart enough and loving enough to be
both quick and entirely merciless.
Now we have approached the most interesting
part of the process for me.
I took my initial feedback and I put it in
my head with the idea and sat there.
During the process, you have lots of great
ideas about the idea and how to make the idea
perfect.
What's not happening is the idea is not actually
becoming real.
It's just becoming cooler inside of your brain.
We call this brain crack, and Ze Frank has
freed me from my addiction to it.
So, I brain-cracked this idea for like a year,
and then I went to LeakyCon, where I got re-inspired
about books and adaptations and how people
should read the book first.
I needed a domain name, went to bustaname.com,
begrudgingly settled on a domain name that
had a number in it, and this may not have
been the best decision in the world, but I
want to emphasize that it WAS a decision.
Making an unperfect decision is far, far better
than not making a decision, which is the worst
possible decision you could make.
Then I went into my design software, Fireworks,
and I made up a logo and I tweeted it and
I put it on my tumblr.
And lots of people gave me great feedback
and tons of amazing genius ideas about how
to make readit1st better.
And I ignored all of them.
Readit1st needs one thing: to do its job,
it needs a newsletter.
And so that's all we did to start.
We also went through about a dozen logo incarnations
on tumblr which was a really rewarding critique
for me.
And then I, executive decision, settled on
a logo which we are now stuck with-- not because
it was the best logo possible, but because
we need to move on!
Then I designed a website around the logo
all by myself.
I did this because I'm a passable designer.
And then because I'm no longer a passable
html coder, I sent it off to a company called
psd2html which changed my design into an actual
webpage.
Then I suckered a friend of mine, Sam Rudge,
into making the code that makes the whole
site work.
And then I suckered my brother, John Green
into, uh, writing the write few editions of
the readit1st newsletter.
The first one will be going out Friday morning.
Never worry about asking people to do favors
for you, especially when they're not huge,
gigantic hunks of time.
BUT!
If money starts to exist with a project, always
remember those people who helped you and reward
them for that.
With money.
Do I need to say that?
Reward them with money!
I do not know if this is a good idea.
That's the thing about ideas.
You will never know if it's a good idea until
you make it real!
And when the world doesn't like the idea,
that is called failure.
And it sounds and it feels SO much worse than
it is!
I now have a lot of failures under my belt,
and I don't mind so much anymore.
It's an amazing way to feel if you want to
create things.
I mean, obviously success is much more enjoyable,
but if you're so afraid of the failure that
you never do it, your chances of success are
NONE.
And of course I want all of Nerdfighteria
to sign up for readit1st, but I also want
you to know that this isn't something I created
for Nerdfighters.
I created it for the world.
What I did was I created it WITH Nerdfighters.
And I really believe that.
I really believe I couldn't have done any
of this if I didn't have a resource that no
one else in the world has-- except for John
Green.
A group of intelligent, interesting, interested,
savvy, tumblogging, made-of-awesome people.
Thanks, not just for this, but for everything
that we've created together.
Everyone can go and sign up for readit1st.com
now, and don't forget to tell your friends.
John, I will see you on Friday.